die nachrichten des tages heute mit
janna bereits guten abend und herzlich
willkommen fußball und mehr hat norbert
lehmann für sie im sport und spiel gut
schauen wir auf die großen themen heute
kampf um die macht in afghanistan die
taliban rücken immer weiter vor und
bringen eine der größten städte unter
ihre kontrolle
hohe corona zahlen in hamburg in keinem
anderen deutschen bundesland ist sieben
tage incident so stark gestiegen
die menschen am mittelmeer leiden unter
einer rekordhitze temperaturen über 48
grad erschweren auch in italien den
kampf gegen die brände
die taliban rücken auf die afghanische
hauptstadt kabul vor außerdem nahmen sie
am abend offenbar hat ein eine der
größten städte des landes seit dem abzug
fast aller internationaler truppen
kontrollieren die islamisten nun rund
zwei drittel des landes sollten sie ein
kalifat errichten werde es keinen cent
deutscher entwicklungshilfe geben warnt
bundesaußenminister maß den orts kräften
die für die bundeswehr gearbeitet haben
sich hatte maas unterstützung zu andrea
bauer
in afghanistan fällt provinzhauptstadt
um provinzhauptstadt die taliban haben
nun auch gar nie eingenommen 150
kilometer vor der hauptstadt kabul und
auch für die ehemaligen ortskräfte wird
die lage immer gefährlicher
in sogenannten safe hauses in geheimen
unterkünften hat ein ziviler verein etwa
300 von ihnen in kabul untergebracht
einer der für die bundeswehr tätig war
und heute in deutschland lebt erzählt
dass es für viele gerade unmöglich ist
offiziell die ausreise zu beantragen
konnten sie einen pass beantragen
natürlich das dauert sehr sehr lang und
für die orts gelöscht da sie dies selbst
häuser nicht verlassen dürfen ja sie
können auch nicht so einfach gehen und
besser werden tragen sie müssen das
alles geheim halten dass die menschen
nicht aufmerksam werden das in kabul
zehn häuser von mali afghanischer
ortskräfte gibt in der deutschen politik
scheint unterdessen eine art schwarzer
peter spiel begonnen zu haben wer für
die schleppende evakuierung
verantwortlich ist die
verteidigungsministerin sieht die schuld
bei der afghanischen regierung
der limitierende faktor liegt zurzeit
darin dass die afghanische regierung
darauf besteht dass die die ausreisen
afghanischen reisepass haben der
kanzlerkandidat der union dagegen
kritisiert heute mittag überraschend das
auswärtige amt ich höre über was da
alles bürokratisch hin und her
diskutiert wird
und ob der flug bezahlt wird oder nicht
bezahlt wird das auswärtige amt scheint
da
einige bürokratische hemmnisse
aufzubauen diese menschen müssen sehr
schnell eine chance haben nach
deutschland zu kommen
aus dem auswärtigen amt zu diesem
vorwurf bislang keine stellungnahme
schon am morgen allerdings hatte der
außenminister öffentlich hilfe in
aussicht gestellt wir sind zur zeit
dabei ein bis zwei charterflüge zu
organisieren die bis ende des monats
noch einmal eine größere anzahl von
menschen aus dem land heraus gebracht
hat und wir werden dort wo noch visa zu
verteilen sind diese wie sie jetzt in
deutschland teil die sicherheitslage am
hindukusch unterdessen verschlechtert
sich stündlich
wenn sie mehr dazu wissen wollen ins
hätte erfreute live sprechen wir unter
anderem mit einem bundeswehrsoldaten der
in afghanistan im einsatz war ab 1930
auf zdf heute.de und in unserer app
blicken wir jetzt auf die korona
pandemie da steigen in deutschland die
zahlen das robert koch institut meldet
5638 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
2099 mehr als vor einer woche
17 menschen starben innerhalb eines
tages im zusammenhang mit 19 die
bundesweite sieben tage incidents steigt
auf 27,6 und auf der deutschlandkarte
ist zu sehen in einigen ballungsräumen
liegt die inzidenz wieder bei über 50
sowie in hamburg dort liegt die inzidenz
bei 63,6 so hoch wie in keinem anderen
bundesland
sven regn ist der frage nachgegangen
woran das liegt
hafen barkasse nina darf fahren voll
beladen seit zwei monaten wieder am
horizont aber wirft die stark steigende
inzidenz ihre wellen buch voraus
schiffsführer prahl erwartet schweres
fahrwasser wenn es wieder losgeht dass
wir abstand halten müssen da wird das
hier war ein meter fünfzig abstand
beikircher keine leute werden schiff
wird das schwierig seit drei wochen
steigt die inzidenz in hamburg deutlich
stärker als im bundesdurchschnitt 1
zeitpunkt verrät den grund dafür am
schulferien ende springt die kurve fast
schon steil nach oben wir gucken nicht
nur darauf wie viel zahlen haben wir
sondern gucken im moment sehr genau auf
die altersverteilung der infizierten
unterstellen fester spielt sich alles
sehr wesentlich bei den menschen
zwischen 16 und mitte 40 ab so dass wir
im moment noch nicht beunruhigt sind man
muss aber durchaus sagen dass es nicht
selbstverständlich dass alles so positiv
weitergeht die reiserückkehrer haben
also einen spürbaren effekt auf die
infektions entwicklung zumindest in
ballungsräumen das zeigen auch hamburgs
nachbar bundesländern in denen die
ferien ebenfalls zu ende sind vielen
anderen bundesländern steht diese
entwicklung noch bevor es ist zu
erwarten dass wir überall dort wo die
ferien zu ende gehen wenn dann dort auch
wieder vermehrt getestet wird auch mit
steigenden insolvenzen zu rechnen ist
die menge der testungen hat einen ganz
wesentlichen einfluss darauf wie die
inzidenz gerade ist hamburg zieht
bereits erste konkrete konsequenzen auf
dem größten volksfest im norden dem dom
sind seit dieser woche nur noch
siebeneinhalb stadt 900.000 besucher
erlaubt kein riesenproblem aber
möglicherweise ein fingerzeig
die hoffnung ist ja mit einer hohen
impfquote die pandemie den griff zu
bekommen
nun stellt sich die frage wie viele
menschen in deutschland tatsächlich
geimpft sind denn dazu gibt es
widersprüchliche erhebungen des robert
koch instituts die impfquote könnte
höher sein als offiziell gemeldet das
will das lka mit einer weiteren umfrage
überprüfen auch intensivmediziner innen
fordern klarheit
alle die mit der deutschen bahn fahren
brauchen weiterhin starke nerven um zwei
uhr nachts endet heute der streik der
lokführergewerkschaft gdl zumindest
vorerst schon in der kommenden woche
will die gewerkschaft über einen neuen
streik entscheiden auch heute am zweiten
tag sind die auswirkungen des
arbeitskampfes groß im fernverkehr fährt
nur etwa jeder vierte zug und auch im
regional und güterverkehr kommt es zu
zahlreichen ausfällen und verspätungen
ein blick ins rheinland pfälzische
aartal dort bauen auch die
winzerbetriebe nach der flutkatastrophe
mühsam wieder auf was noch zu retten ist
eigentlich ist der weinbau einer der
wichtigsten wirtschaftszweige der region
nun stehen die winzerinnen zum teil vor
den trümmern ihrer existenz
zehn prozent der rebflächen ruiniert
keller überflutet arbeitsgeräte
vollständig zerstört die schäden werden
auf zirka 160 millionen euro geschätzt
aber es gibt hilfe christopher heinze
berichtet in benno gilles weinbergen ist
mittlerweile vieles erledigt der
rebschnitt fast abgeschlossen winzer
kollegen aus anderen anbaugebieten haben
bei ihm wie überall an der ahr geholfen
in gut vier wochen beginnt bereits die
leser ein großteil seiner trauben ist
gesund an den hängen verschont geblieben
das problem in gilles von der flut
schwer verwüsteten hof kann in diesem
herbst nichts verarbeitet werden
werden dort dann auch
weil das ganze in einem jahr aufzubauen
fast alle weinbaubetriebe an der ahr
sind beschädigt auch die großen
genossenschaften hat es schwer erwischt
dennoch sind sie hier bei der
genossenschaft in mayschoß optimistisch
in wenigen wochen schon die trauben
viele 100 winzer in dieser nur wenig
betroffenen halle zu verarbeiten die
hoffnung darauf dass wir die ernte jetzt
21 einfahren können das was noch
erhalten ist und dass wir damit wird
wenn ich den winter zeigen können und
damit auch im jahr eine verkaufs kapital
mit dem wir dann weiter leben können
also auch die existenzen sichern wird es
wird jahre dauern bis die zerstörten
rebflächen wieder nachgepflanzt sind und
dann auch ertrag liefern hoffnung
schöpfen die winzer mittlerweile auch
aus einer von ihnen selbst initiierten
hilfsaktion flut wein die flaschen
werden so verkauft wie sie nach dem
hochwasser geborgen wurden fast vier
millionen euro hat das bislang
eingebracht was ich glaube ich noch viel
wichtiger finde als das geld was dabei
rauskommt ist die spürbare unterstützung
bedeutet wir reden hier von 40.000
unterstützern und das kommuniziere ich
auch an alle kollegen raus und ich
glaube das gibt uns in der hoffnung eine
hoffnung sie spendet auch benno gilles
und vielen seiner winzerkollegen kraft
für die zukunft
viele im aartal und in den anderen
flutgebieten stehen vor dem nichts und
brauchen weiterhin hilfe wenn auch sie
spenden wollen das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe hat ein konto dafür
die iban lautet de 65 104 106 100 104
106 100 stichwort zdf hochwasser und
mehr informationen gibt es unter spenden
punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 8
am 26 september wird ja nicht nur ein
neuer bundestag gewählt sondern in
mecklenburg vorpommern auch ein neuer
landtag der wahlkampf dreht sich dabei
vor allem um die themen wirtschaft und
bildung in den umfragen liegt die spd
von ministerpräsident in spe sich vorn
sie regiert mit der cdu bernd mosebach
über den wahlkampfauftakt
die staatskanzlei in schwerin seit vier
jahren ihr arbeitsplatz manuela schwesig
und wenn es nach ihr geht soll das auch
so bleiben wir wollen wieder stärkste
kraft im land werden mit der spd und ich
möchte gerne meine arbeit als
ministerpräsidentin fortsetzen wir
wollen unser land voranbringen starke
wirtschaft gute löhne soziale
gerechtigkeit und ökologische
verantwortung michael sack cdu als
landrat ohne landespolitische erfahrung
seit 2006 regiert seine partei als
juniorpartnerin der spd ein wahlziel
erhalt und ausbau der ländlichen
infrastruktur die chancen im ländlichen
raum müssen endlich gehoben werden wir
haben es gerade die letzten eineinhalb
jahren gesehen dass viele menschen im
ländlichen raum suchen gerade aus den
ballungsräumen und hier muss endlich die
muss die bremse endlich gelöst werden
zweitstärkste fraktion im jetzigen
landtag die afd der landesverband von
nikolaus kramer gilt als zerstritten
hauptwahlkampfthemen flüchtlingspolitik
corona maßnahmen und bildung wenn wir
regierungsverantwortung hätten dann
würden wir diese bildungsmisere endlich
beenden da würden wir mehr lehrer
einstellen dann würden wir vor allen
dingen in erster linie viel mehr für
unsere familien tun für die kinder tun
in diesem land bildung war schon während
der legislaturperiode das hauptthema der
linken und ist es auch jetzt im
wahlkampf von simone oldenburg in den
schulen mecklenburg vorpommerns knirscht
es an allen ecken und enden wir brauchen
1000 zusätzliche lehrkräfte wir brauchen
ein gesundes und kostenloses mittagessen
und investitionen von 250 millionen euro
pro jahr die doppelspitze bei den grünen
nach letzten umfragen könnte ihnen der
einzug in den landtag gelingen wir
brauchen einen großen ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien so war sowohl
photovoltaik als auch windkraft wir
müssen auch im naturschutz vorankommen
wir brauchen weniger pestizide auf den
äckern und wir müssen den moorschutz
voranbringen auch die fdp könnte die
rückkehr in den landtag nach zehn jahren
abwesenheit schaffen ihr thema
bürokratieabbau es wird alles schneller
und es wird der reguliert das verspreche
ich auf jeden fall meine wette ist jede
dritte verordnung hier in mecklenburg
vorpommern kann weg die wahlkampf ist
eröffnet mecklenburg vorpommern hat die
wahl in
lübeck ist die carlebach synagoge
offiziell wieder eröffnet worden sie ist
eine der wenigen synagogen in
deutschland die die nazis nicht
vollständig zerstörten sechs jahre lang
wurde sie saniert bei der feierlichen
zeremonie erklärte der präsident des
zentralrats der juden schuster durch
bauwerke wie dieses werde jüdisches
leben in deutschland sichtbar in den
90er jahren gab es zwei brandanschläge
auf die synagoge
und wir schauen ins ausland in polen ist
die regierungskoalition unter führung
der nationalkonservativen pis zerbrochen
trotzdem kam das umstrittene neue
rundfunkgesetz durch das parlament in
einer turbulenten sitzung und nachdem
die abstimmung wiederholt wurde gab es
eine knappe mehrheit für das gesetz
sieht vor dass sendelizenzen nur noch an
europäische unternehmen vergeben werden
und trifft den regierungskritischen
sender tvn der in amerikanischer hand
ist
nach äthiopien im norden des landes in
der abtrünnigen region t3 begann vor gut
neun monaten ein konflikt der längst zu
einem krieg geworden ist die kämpfe
zwischen der volksbefreiungsfront und
regierungstruppen traumatisieren die
ganze region schutzsuchende geraten
immer wieder zwischen die fronten es
gibt gerichte berichte von massakern und
sexualisierter gewalt laut un schätzung
wurden rund
22.500 frauen und mädchen opfer von
übergriffen so seien von der
sgs sind die frauen und mädchen die
unter dem krieg in der konfliktregion t3
besonders zu leiden haben sie werden
sexuell verstümmelt missbraucht
vergewaltigt sowie diese 27-jährige
waren 23 soldaten in der wüste ich war
völlig überrumpelt alle diese 23 haben
eine frau vergewaltigt mich als ich
schrie haben sie sich fast erwürgt
zu hunderten kommen die frauen in die
noch funktionierenden krankenhäuser auf
zutiefst traumatisiert die schwere der
verbrechen sei schockierend so die
menschenrechtsorganisation amnesty
international
die umstände weisen auf kriegsverbrechen
hin manche sogar auf verbrechen gegen
die menschlichkeit ein die brutalität
ist
extrem die täter sind soldaten sowohl
die eritreischen wieder äthiopischen
armee seit ende letzten jahres kämpfen
sie gemeinsam gegen die in der provinz
tigray herrschende volksbefreiungsfront
tplf auch vergewaltigungen gehören zu
ihren kriegswaffen der konflikt droht
weiter zu eskalieren nicht zuletzt weil
der im juni wieder gewählte
premierminister ahmed gerade erst die
entwickler dazu aufrief der armee
beizutreten und gegen die tiger zu
kämpfen es ist ein erbitterter kampf mit
tausenden opfern und so schätzt ruhe in
mindestens 170 tausend menschen auf der
flucht
der mittelmeerraum sind derzeit viele
orte von extremer hitze betroffen auf
der italienischen insel sizilien
beispielsweise wurden temperaturen von
48,8 grad celsius gemessen offiziell
bestätigt dass dieser rekordwert aber
noch nicht immerhin die feuerwehr gibt
leichte entwarnung die waldbrände auf
der insel seien unter kontrolle
anders in der region kalabrien
dort ist die lage noch kritischer
annette hilsenbeck berichtet soll tragen
bringt es in süditalien kämpft die
feuerwehr gegen die flammen alleine in
kalabrien sind heute 100
feuerwehrmannschaften im einsatz
bekämpfen mehrere großbrände vier
menschen kamen bisher durch die feuer
ums leben wie der besitzer dieses hauses
er war hinausgegangen wollte seinen vier
retten seine ehefrau verzweifelt
mein mann hat sein blut sein leben in
dieses land gesteckt und was
nicht
auch auf sizilien hat es in der nacht
noch gebrannt die feuer sind inzwischen
unter kontrolle tausende hektar haben
die flammen hier verschlungen das
brandrisiko nach wie vor hoch eine
hitzewelle mit rekordtemperaturen die
italien so noch nicht erlebt hat haben
den süden des landes auch in den
nächsten tagen im griff
die hitze trägt zu den vorjahren bei
doch menschen sollen sie verursacht
haben offizielle stellen sprechen von
brandstiftung
löschen ein feuer und sofort brennt das
nächste was diese situation ist geplant
und zwar nicht von einer person alleine
da stecken mehreren dahinter
die staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt bereits
in einigen der brandfälle die
bürgermeister von der region haben
derweil gefordert dass der notstand für
kalabrien und sizilien ausgerufen wird
sie fürchten dass es weitere brände
geben wird
auch im süden der türkei sind erneut
waldbrände ausgebrochen von denen einige
außer kontrolle sind auf der anderen
seite kämpfen die menschen im norden des
landes nach starken regenfällen mit den
folgen schwerer überschwemmungen
hunderte orte wurden überflutet
besonders betroffen die schwarzmeer
provinz kastamonu die wassermassen
zerstörten häuser und brücken rissen
autos mit sich mindestens neun menschen
kamen listen ums leben
und wir kommen zum sport zu norbert
unterzieht ein großer deutscher
handballer anschluss stressiger kapitän
uwe gensheimer der wird die
nationalmannschaft verlassen nach dem
enttäuschenden olympia turnier nicht nur
der 34 jährige tritt zurück
bundestrainer gislason muss auf weiter
routiniers bei der handball-em in fünf
monaten verzichten seine entscheidung
habe er schon vor den olympischen
spielen getroffen einen konkreten grund
dafür nannte der 34-jährige heute nicht
der ganz grosse titel war nicht dabei
mit mir vergönnt aber es war eine
unheimlich tolle zeit die ich nicht mehr
missen möchte uwe
merkt dass er selber dass es vielleicht
zeit ist sportlich vielleicht noch
schwerwiegender der rücktritt von
steffen weinhold
abwehrchef hendrik pekeler will eine
längere pause einlegen und torwart
johannes bitter 38 nur noch im notfall
aushelfen da verlieren wir natürlich
viel erfahrung und viel qualität nach
zwei enttäuschenden turnieren ist
bundestrainer alfred gislason nun also
zum umbau gezwungen
das auswärts debüt von bundestrainer
hansi flick wird ohne deutsche anhänger
stattfinden die fifa lässt aufgrund
hoher corona infektionszahlen in europa
keine gästefans bei den wm quali spielen
in liechtenstein und in island im
september zu ja und nächster titel für
thomas tuchel und dem fc chelsea nach
dem gewinn der champions league nun auch
noch der sieg im uefa supercup gegen
villarreal ein finale das erst nach
verlängerung und elfmeterschießen knapp
entschieden wurde
alles richtig gemacht thomas tuchels
emotionale geste nachvollziehbar der von
ihm fürs elfmeterschießen extra eigene
wechselte torhüter käfer mit goldenem
griff chelsea triumphiert das spiel
selbst mit wenigen höhepunkten die
flanke von kai herbert erreicht hat emc
ex 27 minute die frühe führung der blues
wie real zunächst mit latte vor
und pfosten nach der pause dann der
verdiente ausgleich durch scherer moreno
1 zu 1 nach verlängerung bis zu seinem
großen auftritt keeper hält
champions-league-sieger fc chelsea
gewinnt auf den europäischen supercup
das was vom sturz danke schön euer land
und ich kann ihn jetzt eins versprechen
hochsommerliche aussichten die kommen
gleich und zwar von katja honnefer
einzelne gewitter sind allerdings nicht
ausgeschlossen
das heute journal das sehen sie um 21 45
mit claus kleber machen wir es gut wir
sehen
[Musik]
guten abend die hitzewelle am mittelmeer
die bleibt auch weiter bestehen auch
heute lagen die temperaturen zwischen 40
und 50 grad da ist es bei uns in
mitteleuropa doch deutlich angenehmer
bei uns stiegen die temperaturen auf 25
bis 32 grad und nur über die mitte zogen
auch mal dichtere wolkenfelder jetzt in
der nacht sinken die werte am oberrhein
bis 20 grad wieder wird es zum beispiel
im bergischen land oder auch in der
oberpfalz mit zwölf grad und heute nacht
ist es häufig klar in der zweiten
nachthälfte aber kann es aus der
schweissen aus den alpen heraus einige
schauer und gewitter geben die werden
dann aber schnell wieder in sich
zusammenfallen und so erwartet uns ein
freundlicher vormittag das allerdings
ändert sich am nachmittag in der
schwülen luft entwickeln sich dann
schauer und gewitter hier vom
schwarzwald bis etwa zum thüringer wald
und auch in bayern ist so ganz lokal mal
ein heftiger gewitterschauer nicht ganz
ausgeschlossen auch im nordwesten ändert
sich was denn von der nordseeküste
ziehen dichtere wolken heran die auch
regenschauer dabei haben deswegen
steigen morgen dort die temperaturen bis
auf 22 23 grad sonst werden 26 bis 31
grad und in den nächsten tagen geht es
sehr sommerlich weiter bei temperaturen
bis 30 grad am sonntag